CHRIS YING: My
name is Chris Ying,
I'm the editor in chief of
the Lucky Peach magazine.
Welcome, to your own campus.
[LAUGHTER]
Another authors at
Google event, this time
with Chef Thomas McNaughton
of Flour + Water,
Salumeria, and Central
Kitchen in San Francisco.
Three wildly successful places,
that I imagine many of you
have visited.
AUDIENCE: Yummy.
CHRIS YING: Yummy, we
got a yummy back there.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Yay.
CHRIS YING: And we're
here to kind of talk
and celebrate your new cookbook,
"Flour + Water: Pasta."
Let's just jump
right in, unless you
want to say more nice things.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: No
please, that's perfect.
CHRIS YING: So the first
thing I found interesting
about this book was that the
very first voices we hear from
are not yours.
They're from your two
business partners--
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Right.
CHRIS YING: --kind of giving
the background of how Flour +
Water came to be, and their
sort of somewhat circuitous path
to be restaurateurs.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that decision
and that story, I think
that one of the-- the book
is really in three parts, and
the idea behind those three
parts were, the
first one is that it
had to be a story of
behind the scenes.
And I think in this day and
age, you know with reality TV,
and everyone wants to see what
goes on behind the scenes.
And we really wanted
to kind of tell
the story of how the
restaurant, Flour + Water,
came to fruition.
And that really started with
my two business partners,
David White and David Steel.
And the author,
Paolo Lucchesi, he
wanted to have some
sort of rhythm to it.
And so, if you open the
book right off the bat.
It has rhythm, and
it has, it's supposed
to kind of draw
you in little bit.
And I thought it was great,
it kind of-- just slightly
different type face-- and it
kind of hops back and forth
their story and how it
kind of intertwines.
And one starts in Ireland,
one starts in South Jersey,
and how my two partners
met at that time.
CHRIS YING: I mean, it's
sort of like a classic tale,
in restaurants of the chef,
and his business partners
never seeing
eye-to-eye on things.
But it seems, based on
the story you tell here
that you guys have a very
different relationship
and that--
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: I think that
to-- a restaurant is a crazy,
it's a crazy business
venture, it's
a crazy experience
every single day,
and we are three
people that come,
we approach a restaurant three
completely different ways.
And I think that we value
each other's experience.
It's very much, I'm
kind of jumping ahead,
but it's how the restaurants
run a daily basis,
that it's a complete
collaborative nature.
And really, every single
decision along the way
funnels down to the three of
us, and there's a veto power.
You need two, you need
to votes out of three,
to pass the law
that is being passed
that day, and that collaborative
nature, in that kind of trust
so we have each other.
I think it's certainly unique.
It doesn't mean
that-- the meeting may
start with us arguing for
45 minutes prior to it,
but um-- Yeah, we each
approach something different,
we bring different perspectives.
Outside perspective, from
outside of our industry
is really, really
important to us.
It's staying away from
the humdrum nature of this
is how it's done
in a restaurant,
and this is how it's done
in a professional kitchen.
So, we value that
collaborative nature
of being able to sit
around a roundtable
and talk about something.
And then, like I said,
arguing 45 minutes
and then we come
up with a solution.
CHRIS YING: And the way
that you first got this job,
was pretty unorthodox too.
Can you tell us about where you
were, and how that happened?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Yeah, I
was traveling a lot in Europe,
and they call it staging.
So staging at a restaurant
means that you can go there
and you work for free.
It's like working
for a blacksmith.
You can watch them work,
and get hands on experience.
And there's an
intellectual property
that goes on with cooking
and professional restaurants,
but there's also a physical.
It's a craft.
You have to use your hands.
The more that you use
your training them,
and so that was always
incredibly important to me.
And I was in Bologna, working
at a pasta laboratorio,
at the time and I just had
to go back to San Francisco.
The honest story
is my girlfriend
was here at the
time, and I really
wanted to move back
to San Francisco,
and working at these amazing
restaurants and on some farms.
I saw a random Craigslist ad
for a chef, for a restaurant,
and I just emailed back.
It was like two sentences.
It was like, I
don't have a resume.
I worked at Gary Danko,
La Folie, and Quince.
I'm coming back to to Marin
and I really want to goat farm.
And that was it.
And it was like,
two sentences long,
and I think I even capitalized
"I really want to goat farm."
And then, my now business
partner Dave White
e-mailed me back,
because we previously
worked together at Quince.
And he's like, Tom is that you?
What the hell are
you talking about?
You want to goat farm?
And we just started to
evolve the conversation.
It was perfect timing.
I was in Bologna, which is
the heart of-- Emilia-Romagna
in Italy is really the heart
of what most Americans think
of as Italian food.
You know, it's Prusciuto de
Parma, Tagetelli Bolagnase,
lasagna, fresh rolled egg
doughs, Parmesan Reggiano,
balsamic vinegar
and he was talking
about opening this incredibly
rustic Italian restaurant,
and it was focused on pizza.
I thought that Flour + Water
was the worst name ever
possibly made up
for a restaurant.
I'm still dealing
with it right now.
Nobody ever forgets it though,
which is a great thing.
And it was just perfect timing.
It was being in Emila-Romagna.
My majority of my
restaurant background
was from more fine
dining restaurants.
And I just fell
in love with that.
The rustic nature of
the food, but also
the culture of how Italians eat
and their philosophy on food.
We want to go back
to San Francisco.
There's so much aligned with
the values in San Francisco,
and dealing with food as
well, that it was just
kind of really,
really good timing.
But I wasn't going to-- I
refused the partnership.
And I wasn't going
to be a partner.
And I was just going to
act like consulting chef.
And then after the
first couple of months
it just, so much of
like, blood, sweat,
and tears went into
producing Flour +
Water that the partnership
just kind of seemed natural.
CHRIS YING: And do you
have a goat farm now, or?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: We
do not have a goat farm.
We're so close.
CHRIS YING: So you're
a bit of a failure.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Yeah, absolutely.
CHRIS YING:
Achieving that dream.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: I just
keep getting back up.
CHRIS YING: No, but so that
trip you took to Italy,
you know, you had been
cooking in very high quality
restaurants in San
Francisco in the Bay Area,
and then you made this sort
of decision to go to Italy
and do something
a little bit less
refined to get in touch
with something else.
And in a lot of ways you
were making the same journey
that Alice Waters
or Jeremiah Tower
had done 30 or 40
years before you.
And they had had
that same epiphany
that change the way they cook.
So, what was that
you encountered
in these places in
Bologna and Emilia-Romagna
that struck a chord with you?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: I
think that just kind
of traveling the whole
time that, if you--
growing up and having a
completely ADD nature as a kid,
I wanted to try a little
bit of everything.
And I first fell in
love with kitchens
because they just coincided
with my personality.
So you're never a master chef.
You're never going to
master cooking and food.
And that's what really
led me to want to travel,
to see different cultures.
If you want to stage and
learn actual techniques,
I tell most of our young
cooks stay in America.
There's no language barrier.
You can be in front chefs.
You can articulate the things
that you want to say to them,
and for you to grab as
much knowledge as possible.
But I always say that going
to France, even Italy, Spain,
Germany, working three-star
Michelin restaurants,
I wasn't nervous at all, because
there's a common food language.
I don't need to speak
German to understand
who's an hour behind
in the kitchen.
You could just see it on their
face, who needs the most help.
Or you see somebody
picking fava beans.
Like, I know how
to pick fava beans.
I can just belly up and pick
them as fast as I possibly can.
So there's a common
food language
within kitchens that breaks
down that language barrier.
And going to
Emilia-Romagna and going
to pasta laboratorio,
where there's machines.
Pasta machines are
all over Italy.
The metal hand-cranked machines,
they're all over Italy.
They don't exist in the
old walls of Bologna,
and everything's rolled
out by a giant matterello.
It's a massive rolling pin.
And it's like watching
like an artistic show,
as they roll it out.
It's something
completely different.
And it was the first time
I was so incredibly nervous
in a kitchen.
Because it was old ladies that
have been doing it for 40,
50 years of their life.
They go there to gossip
every single day.
They don't even think about the
motions that they go through.
And that craft, that
one single craft,
to put it under a microscope,
was terrifying to me.
I was shaking the
first time they
let me pick up one
of the rolling pins.
It was just so specific, so
specific to that culture,
that I was enthralled
with the entire process.
CHRIS YING: Can you
explain for everybody
this idea of the
pasta laboratorio?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Pasta laboratorio
sounds like it's Google robots
coming in, napping pods.
CHRIS YING: They probably
have a laboratorio somewhere
here-- a pasta lab.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: But it's
a bunch of wooden tables.
And it's essentially just
And it's something
that they produce.
So a salumeria is
something that is based off
of historic shops in Bologna
that sell cured meats,
and they sell
pasta by the pound.
Some will specialize in
a little bit more cheese.
Some may do sandwiches from it.
But essentially,
it's cured meats
and it's pasta that
they sell by the pound.
Every single one
of those salumerias
has a pasta laboratorio that's
associated with it, producing
literally 200 kilos of
fresh pasta a single day.
And the one that I worked
at, Bruno and Franco,
was just 12 old ladies working
around various wooden tables.
And every single thing
is rolled out by hand.
Which means that it's created
over a four-foot rolling pin.
And they roll out
a sheet of pasta
that's three feet by four feet.
And they do it in about
15 minutes per sheet.
And it's just something
that-- also why
I've always connected
with Italian food
is that it's so
based off of culture.
The nuance of what
goes on from a rolling
pin to a wooden table,
it's two porous natures.
It's really porous.
It's not like flat metal.
And so it goes
down to the science
of how that pasta
behaves, and how
it's treated with
the sauce, and why
that's so important to them.
But that's not the main
reason why they do it.
They do it based off of
what their grandmother did,
what their
great-grandmother did.
It's based off of tradition.
Some you could ask, why do
you roll it out with a pin,
you'd get this really, really
archaic-- you just don't ask.
We roll it out by pins.
And then some answers would talk
about the nuances of the wood.
It's a very special place
that you don't see a lot.
CHRIS YING: It's interesting.
I spoke to the chef
Massimo Bottura
from this three Michelin
star hypermodernist
restaurant in Modena.
And there they use roto vaps and
all sorts of crazy contraptions
when it comes o making
the tagliatelle.
They will only do
it on a wooden table
with a wooden rolling
pin, because for whatever
grandmotherly reasons, plus
the real reasons that you're
talking about, it does matter.
You can't improve
upon this thing.
That seems very rustic.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Very, very shortly on I
had to calm my American-esque
questions to them.
It was like, well, how come you
guys don't stay an hour longer
and roll out another 25 kilos,
and then you'd make this money,
and then you can
buy this machine?
And why don't you have an
automated dryer for the pasta?
And they just weren't
interested in it.
It was like, I'm going home
to cook to feed my family.
That food culture--
or even a culture--
is so directly
connected with food.
That's why I thought
traveling was so important.
It's not just training
yourself for a chef,
or working on your knife
skills, or learning
how to roll something
by rolling pin.
Culture is so
interrelated with food.
It's the common denominator
of every single person
in this room, is that
we all have to eat.
We all don't have
fancy cafeterias
that make this amazing
food on a daily basis.
But we're constantly--
whether you
aren't that interested
in food, you're
talking about food
on an weekly basis.
Maybe where do we
eat tomorrow night?
CHRIS YING: Do
you feel like it's
difficult to translate
that kind of spirit
of Italian eating culture to
the San Francisco restaurant
culture?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: It's great.
The reason why,
when we were first
approached to write
the book, it was we
want to do a Flour
+ Water cookbook.
And it never really
made sense to me.
I was like, well, such
a young restaurant.
And I just didn't like
the scarcity of it.
And when we finally
decided to do pasta,
it made so much sense to me.
Because I think there's
a mystery behind pasta.
There's a mystery behind pasta,
because not a lot of people
replicate it.
We may have all, in this
room, been in the backyard
and thrown a steak on a grill.
And we're a little bit
more comfortable with that.
And we've produced that before.
There's a mystery behind pasta.
And people, especially
in San Francisco,
love Italian, rustic
Italian restaurants,
because it's not something that
they make every single day.
It's not a part of that
daily culture to, like, OK.
Let's get the rolling pin
and start rolling out.
I think that you certainly see
a resurge of people putting more
time into creating their
meals throughout the day.
But I think it's based
off of something good,
and that's post-war how do
we have the family work?
How do we can items?
How do we can something
and have it available
all across America?
And that American
mentality of making
it faster and faster and faster.
I think it's kind of reached a
point where people are slowly
stepping back and saying
is this a food culture
that were proud of?
Not to say there's
something wrong with it.
It's based off of
something good.
It's just going home and cooking
for two hours with a family
is engraved in them there.
And it's something that
they don't necessarily
question that.
And sure, you can get
a really fast panini
and a cappuccino on the street.
But that daily
exercise of cooking,
I think that it's interesting
to see it, maybe, slightly
evolve in America.
CHRIS YING: And,
like you said, there
is no real shortage of that
rustic Italian restaurant
in San Francisco.
People go nuts for pasta.
And I want to hear why
Flour + Water stands out.
But you also mentioned
that originally the Davids
had a different vision for what
Flour + Water was going to be.
And it evolved into
something what it is now.
Can you talk about what it is
now and how it became that?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: What is now?
I don't even know
what it is now.
The train has gone
off the tracks.
But the original
vision, first, when
I would buy two hours with
the phone cards in Italy,
and just sit in a
phone booth and talk
to them about the
business plan and how
we were developing
the business plan.
They wanted incredibly,
incredibly rustic Italian food.
It was your antipasti was
a bowl of marinated beets,
and that's it.
Just marinated, and it's rustic,
and it's sitting in a bowl.
Pizza is a huge focus
of the restaurant.
When we first
opened up, everyone
thought we were a pizzeria.
And we were selling a billion
pizzas every single night.
In the first week, we sold
four times the amount of pizzas
nightly than we do
now, because pasta's
taken such a
forefront to the menu.
And my approach
was, why can't we
have a seemingly rustic
atmosphere in nature
of a restaurant and still
have refinement on the plate?
And it's something that I think
so many restaurants strive for.
And a lot of it, you
can't really explain.
It's like how can you have a
pizza whizzing by your head,
and it's cramped,
an it's crowded,
and it's uncomfortable
to wait for a table.
And then have something
that's put on the plate
that maybe you could swap out
at a Michelin star restaurant.
I got increasingly--
not annoyed,
but increasingly I want to
feel as normal as possible.
I want to feel as
comfortable as possible.
And if I have to put on a
suit that I wear once a year,
and I sit down at a formal
table and feel like I
have to whisper the whole time.
Someone comes over and
you're like, oh, sorry.
Why can't we have this
incredibly rustic nature
of an atmosphere, and then still
have refinement on a plate?
Michelin-starred
restaurant in New York City
that serves a burger.
That burger's so
incredibly rustic.
It's not made very
differently than most burgers.
But it's that
attention to detail.
I want that burger
perfectly cooked.
I want that bun
perfectly toasted,
that blue cheese
should always melt
a certain way on top of it.
I think having a rustic
restaurant doesn't
mean that you have to
lose that attention
to detail in every single thing.
How clean the floor
is in the kitchen,
and having a
kitchen that can run
like a Michelin-starred
restaurant,
I think, affects the food.
CHRIS YING: I
wanted to go back--
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Did I-- I don't even
think I answered that.
CHRIS YING: Enh,
doesn't even matter.
I don't even know what I asked.
No.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: We're back.
We're back.
CHRIS YING: Just kidding.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
We're coming back.
CHRIS YING: We did a great job.
I want to go back to those
formative experiences
you were having in Bologna.
You talk about,
in the book, going
beyond just like to the
trattorias on the street
and just the tourist places, and
finding these experiences that
are under the table.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Sure.
CHRIS YING: And I
wondered if that's
something that your average
person can go to Italy
and find, or if being a chef,
being a cook, doing stages,
opens those doors for you?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Yeah, certainly.
I was so fortunate when I
rented an apartment in Bologna.
I didn't realize that I
was renting an apartment
from someone that
does culinary tours.
And it wasn't like
him on a big bus.
It was him taking
people in his car
and bringing them to the
prosciutto factories,
to where they make Parmesan,
seeing them firsthand.
And certainly in southern Italy,
there's different dialects,
there's a really rude
comment to somebody
is, you're the type of person
that eats at a restaurant.
That's slang for you
have no idea what you're
talking about when
it comes to food.
And so much of the
amazing experiences
that I had were
at people's table.
And, also, understanding
that culture.
When it comes to pasta,
I've been at tables
where someone's started grating
a truffle on top of a pasta,
and half the table's
in an uproar.
And they're like, what
the hell are you doing?
That doesn't belong
on the pasta.
And like for me, it's
like, keep shaving.
Just keep shaving.
More truffle.
That culture, and how it
interplays with that dining
atmosphere, is so important.
It's like being in San
Francisco and seeing people--
I'll see tourists
walking through there,
I'm like, how did they
get to this neighborhood?
This is terrible.
Not saying like they're in
a not-cool neighborhood.
They're going to
Fisherman's Wharf.
And they're like, well,
I had this chowder bowl,
and this is San Francisco food.
This is crazy.
I think it's just that
I love understanding
what goes into a city.
I would never want
to travel to a city
again that I didn't have
that insider viewpoint.
I think that's so important.
I think I was really
fortunate enough
to find that in a
foreign country.
CHRIS YING: It's
funny to me, given
how much Americans-- and San
Franciscans, specifically--
love Italian food, and how
much influence Italian food has
had on California cooking,
how many things get crazily
mistranslated when
they're brought here.
And I think that things
like from Emilia-Romagna
and Bologna-- like
tortellini, for example--
feels like one of the most
tortured things in the world.
What is that supposed
to look like?
What is tortellini about?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Tortellini in brodo
is like the pinnacle of
Bologna or Emilia-Romagna food.
It's used as a standard
of whether it's
sub-par or traditional.
I think that you can't take--
I keep going back to culture,
but you can't take a trattoria
in the middle of Italy
and place in San Francisco
and it be a success.
You can't take Flour + Water
and put it in the middle of Rome
and think that it's
going to be a success.
Because there's different--
maybe Italian and American food
is easier to compare,
but think of textures
of certain Asian cultures,
and some of those dishes
not really relating
to an American palate.
I think it's the same thing
with any sort of food culture.
And it kind of gets adapted.
And maybe it starts
as a good thing,
adapting it to a
different culture.
But balsamic vinegar is one of
the most protected processes
in Italy.
You can't have Extravecchio
25-year-old balsamic,
has to be a jar, or has to
be put into a bottle, that's
specific to where that bottle
and that glass is blown.
It's a very, very
specific shape.
An then it has to get
a seal of approval.
And then it's Extravecchio
balsamic vinegar traditionale.
It's so protected.
You go in the
supermarket here, and you
get a gallon of caramel.
It's literally like caramel
that has acid introduced to it.
Middle America that's
only seen that big thing
of balsamic vinegar,
do they really
understand the culture
of balsamic vinegar?
And it kind of gets bastardized.
I think that, too, it's
like, more, bigger, more.
CHRIS YING: You worked
in Italian restaurants
before you made this
seminal trip to Bologna.
And then you talk about
when you're in Bologna,
just that really
opening your eyes
to how pasta is
supposed to be eaten.
How did your view of cooking
it and eating it change?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: I just
think going to that source
is so enlightening.
For the cookbook, we bugged
the hell out of Harold McGee--
if anybody knows "On
Food and Cooking"--
we would just keep buying
him lunch at Salumeria.
Come on, we'll buy you lunch.
And we'd entice him out.
We'd just basically
interview him
the entire time
for the cookbook.
"On Food and Cooking"
was written a year
after I was born.
And it's still the most stolen
cookbook from our test kitchen.
Because it has so
much relevance today.
He was one of the
first food scientists
to really put food forward.
It's understanding how
it behaves, and just
being incredibly
inquisitive about just
such a specific item.
It's just pasta.
How does it behave?
How does it eat?
What are the traditional sauces
that it's accompanied with?
There's something
that's protected
with that pasta that's like,
truffles don't belong on there.
I love that how
that forces somewhat
of a different creative nature.
So stick to the tradition.
And we say that the
food at Flour + Water
is regional Italian food without
turning our backs on California
ingredients.
You're not going to see that
many avocados over there.
And I didn't go to
Bologna to be like, wow,
they use avocados here, too.
This is great.
Let's bring it back
to Flour + Water.
But it was that
Italian sensibility--
what grows around you,
treating it simply.
So much of that has to do with
how pasta is treated there.
How it's behaving.
And then from a restaurant
setting, it's like, well,
how are they slightly drying it?
How do they store it?
CHRIS YING: How does that
creative process at Flour +
Water work?
Does everything begin with
the traditional references,
every shape preexisting?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: We buy
our food from small farms.
And the tagline that
everyone uses now--
small farms and whole animals.
And we don't really think of
a dish and then order in food.
We just order the best
possible food we can,
and we say, OK, well, what do
I want to do with that lam?
Today it's lamb shoulders.
Tomorrow it's lamb belly.
The next day it's lamb leg.
That feeds the creative
nature to the menu.
As far as the
pasta program goes,
we want to adhere--
we don't want
it to be too much of a
blasphemy about that pasta.
Tortellini in brodo.
In my opinion, it's
tortellini in brodo.
It should be served in brodo.
So it shouldn't be picked up
in a cheesy Alfredo sauce.
It's tortellini in brodo.
It's meant to be in brodo.
Well, we're in
California, and we
have 12 extra cases of tomatoes
that a farmer gave to us,
and they're really beautiful.
We can make tomato
water and serve around
that tortellini in
a broth, but that
broth we made of tomato water.
We can serve it as a lightened
dish inside of summertime.
So it's still sticking
to that tradition,
saying well, it's
brodo, but what
do we have around us right now?
Let's create this
broth out of tomato.
I think that we tried
to adhere to it,
but then we always put that
little California twist
on the end of it.
CHRIS YING: Do you ever get
hardliner Italian people
in there who are just
like, this isn't Italian?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Italian people
are the worst people to
cook for in the world.
Whether they're Italian American
or whether they're straight
off the boat, they want to tell
you how their mother did it.
This is good, but my
mother-- Yeah, certainly.
And I think that the biggest
compliment that we get--
and it seems like we get it
all the time-- is when Italian
comes in, they order something
that is seemingly not
traditionally Italian,
and the response
is, this is so Italian.
And maybe that avocado
salad, but that sensibility
of what goes into it is
that Italian sensibility.
And that, to me, is the
ultimate compliment.
It's not like, my mother
used to put a little bit more
nutmeg in the
broth, and you know.
But yeah, it's a huge
compliment to hear that.
CHRIS YING: One
of things I really
love about this book is
just how in-depth you
go with these things.
We've probably heard lots of
fresh pasta dough recipes,
but then there's four pages of
pretty small type describing
it.
And I also really
like the thinking
that goes into arriving
at these methods.
You talk about your experience
with in the laboratorio,
and the women only wanting
to rest their dough
for 18 to 24 hours.
But 30 minutes is enough here.
Or one of my favorite
things is this idea
that I had never even read about
in a cookbook of absorption
versus adsorption.
Actually, will you just
explain that a little bit?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: That
was a Harold McGee lunch
where we were like,
well, what goes on here?
I think that to back
it up, the book--
pasta-- I'll open
a pasta cookbook,
and it's just written word.
And I have no idea
what it's saying.
I'm like, it's so complicated.
It's like right
lateral triangle into.
You have to do math to figure
out how to create this shape.
It was so important to
us that, like, let's
get as geeky as we possibly
can about this subject,
but make it as
PC-friendly as possible.
As friendly in nature
of someone that
knows pasta and wants to
learn something about it to
we've just used flour and
eggs for the first time.
How do we dive into the subject
and still engage people?
And it was written
word, and we found
that photos were
so important to us.
Because you can have
this completely elaborate
thought-out paragraph, and
then you turn the page,
and it's like, oh, OK.
Because I'm such
a visual person.
But it's that single subject,
diving in as much as possible.
We created a dough room
to create all this pastas
and breads.
And then we created a test
kitchen for the cookbook.
And we really like--
this is permanent.
You can do little edits.
Maybe we make it to
a second printing.
But it's permanent.
It's out there.
And that was it's terrifying
to me, because I really
wanted to A, make sure all
the recipes actually worked,
then anything we said that
we're held accountable to.
And there's cookbooks that
I read that's like, oh. man.
That's just wrong.
It's crazy that that went
through all the edits.
And one of the things that I
was teaching all of the cooks
is, I do say I was
culinarily abused
as a child in South Jersey.
And my mother used
to boil spaghetti,
to take the lid off of the
Prego can and heat up the sauce,
and then put the
spaghetti in a bowl
and then just pour the
sauce on top of it.
And forever, I was
teaching, we cook
all of our pastas 80% of
the way in pasta water,
and then 20% of the
way in the sauce.
It's always so important to me.
And I was always
teaching these cooks
there's two things that happen.
The pasta itself is weeping
a little bit of the starch
into the sauce itself.
It's helping to
stabilize the sauce
and concentrate the sauce.
And also, two, the pasta's
absorbing all this flavor.
So it's heavily salted water.
It's absorbing
that salted water.
You put it in the sauce, it's
absorbing all the flavors
of that amazing
way-braised pork shoulder.
CHRIS YING: And this
is super common.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Common knowledge,
is what I was taught.
I said that to Harold,
and he starts laughing.
You're wrong.
You are just wrong.
And I was saying that it was
absorbing all that flavor.
Starch is water-soluble.
So starch and that pasta
and that wheat-based product
can only absorb water.
It can't absorb any fats.
You can't cook pasta
in a fat and then
have it hydrate, right?
It'll absorb it all.
Everything that's romanticized
and amazing about that braise
is mostly essential oils
that come off of the herbs,
all these things, the fat that's
rendered off from the product.
What it is is that the pasta
is only absorbing water.
It's literally you
have all this braise,
and it's literally
just hydrating itself
with just water.
If you cook
spaghetti in red wine
and you look at that
spaghetti, there's
really only a red
wine ring around it.
It's only pulling out all the
H2O from the braise itself.
Adsorption with a D is a
term that he taught me,
that it's how products adhere
to the outside of that noodle.
So that matterello
makes an amazing texture
on the outside of that noodle,
because you're rolling it
from that wooden rolling
pin on the wooden board.
Its porous nature is putting
all of these little crevices,
these little nooks and crannies,
around all of that pasta
that you can barely
even see by the eye.
And that's giving
adsorption the upper hand,
because it's able
to link more things
on the outside of that noodle.
So the concept of finishing
in the pan was right.
The fact of absorption
and absorption
was completely wrong.
CHRIS YING: I just love
how the entire story is
in this book of something that
we all-- if you're a cook,
or if you read
cookbooks, it's just
that's something you think.
Oh, it absorbs the sauce.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: No, totally.
Yeah.
CHRIS YING: And then you
kind of explode that theory,
but still give the
reason why it truly
is good to finish your
pasta in the sauce.
Among the other things
I liked about this book
is that you answer
a question-- which
I'm sure you get
all the time-- which
is what's your favorite pasta?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Is that in there?
CHRIS YING: It's
in there somewhere.
Which was the bigoli.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that dish?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: You can't
really talk about Italian food,
and you certainly can't
talk about pastas,
without talking about how
regional Italy actually is.
Northern Italian food
and southern Italian food
are two completely
different things.
And that goes from not
only each region to region,
but also town to town.
My favorite pasta in the
world is called bigoli.
And bigoli really comes
from a hand-cranked machine
called a torchio.
It's made of brass,
has a brass die.
It's very similar to spaghetti,
but it's hand-cranked,
and it goes through
this brass die,
and it puts this
incredible texture
on the outside of the dough.
The dough itself is
made with semolina.
It has butter,
cream, eggs in it.
It's incredibly enriched.
It's almost like an
enriched udon noodle.
But when it comes
out of this machine,
it looks like a
dreadlock, almost.
It's got this crazy
pulls and textures to it.
I love the texture
of that noodle.
And it adds so much about how
that grips with the sauce.
But the last time, right
before I wrote this book,
I was in Italy.
And I was in Rome trying to
go to all these restaurant
supply stores because my
friend wanted a torchio
to bring back with him.
It's that hand-cranked machine.
And I was going around, like,
do you guys have torchio?
And every single response is
like, what is that, American?
What is it?
What are you talking about?
And I was like, no, no,
no, it's from the Veneto.
It's from Venice,
from Venice, up north.
And it's like, no,
it's from the Veneto.
It's a hand-crank machine.
Every single response was
like, dude, you're in Rome.
No.
We don't have that here.
It was just incredibly
enlightening
about how that plays
on with those regions.
It just doesn't
exist down there.
Torchio is unimportant to them.
CHRIS YING: I sort
of implied that I
would know when time
was coming to an end,
but I have no idea what
time it is whatsoever.
SPEAKER: Few more questions
if there's anything you--
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
I have more questions, but
if you guys have questions.
Does anybody want to--
AUDIENCE: I live a block
away from Flour + Water,
so I feel like
I'm your neighbor.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Say
hello sometime, will you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know.
Seriously.
We eat there pretty regularly.
And I wanted to hear
about the neighborhood.
Because you guys
have been playing
a huge role in neighborhood,
especially now expanding
to Salumeria and
Central Kitchen.
It feels like Gourmet
Alley's going on.
I wanted to know what's your
vision for it and of how
it's evolved?
I've heard a lot of
stories about 09.
You guys kind of put yourself
in the middle of nowhere.
And now you've created
a spot in San Francisco.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Sure.
It's a great question.
In '09, obviously, it was not
the best economical times.
You hear of 12 restaurants
a month, now, opening.
And that's crazy.
And there wasn't a
lot of restaurants
opening at the time.
And we were really lucky
how we went about it.
And that neighborhood I
likened to-- it sounds cheesy,
but it's like Brooklyn.
All of a sudden, people
started finding out about it.
And it was kind of
on the outskirts.
It had big warehouses.
Rent was cheap.
There wasn't a lot of
people moving out of there.
But there was not a lot of
people moving out there,
because it was not the nicest
neighborhood the world.
We have an amazing
picture of Flour + Water
before we broke ground
on construction.
And it was abandoned
for 10 years.
And it was this old El
Salvadorean restaurant.
People still come in
to the restaurant,
and they're like,
oh, six years ago,
we went to the best rave of
our life inside this building.
It was taking a chance.
It was gambling on
that neighborhood.
It's this huge,
amazing juxtaposition
of amazing old Victorian
homes and then industry.
Industry of businesses that are
throughout that neighborhood.
And we just thought
it was a great mix.
And fortunately,
everything on 20th Street
is actually the same landlord.
So we started with
Flour + Water.
We always wanted a salumeria.
We always want somewhere
to sell our cured meats,
to sell the products
that we're proud of,
the salts, the olive oils.
And so Salumeria sits at the
corner of an old German sausage
factory.
And so it really just started
with that tiny little 500
square foot.
And then there was more
building behind it.
And we were like, oh,
what could we do here?
Than there was a little bar
space that wasn't a bar yet.
It was like, what
could we do here?
And then Sightglass moving in.
And we actually took
over the whole building,
and then helped
divide up the leases.
So we didn't want a Burger King.
And Burger King would
never move in there.
But we didn't want a Burger
King moving into this spot.
And so we helped orchestrate
that whole building,
which was really
big at the time.
There's not that
many more plans.
We're opening Cafe du
Nord in Upper Market.
So Cafe du Nord is in the
Swedish American Hall.
It opened in 1907.
Cafe du Nord, since 1907, has
continued to operate as a bar,
even through Prohibition.
It's got these weird
crazy things about it.
So we're partnering, again, with
the bon vivants from Trick Dog.
Fun, underground, lively bar.
And then we're opening
another restaurant
above that called Ache, which
is a Spanish restaurant that we
just made our longtime
chef de cuisine, Ryan
Pollnow, a partner in
the restaurant group,
to help him open
his own restaurant.
So besides that, nothing.
We're doing the whole roof.
It's going to be a crazy year.
Above Trick Dog, the bar,
is a 4,000-square-foot roof.
And we just got
done retrofitting
that whole roof to have a
4000-square-foot garden.
AUDIENCE: And you had
some influence over that.
Everything there is
very high quality.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Yeah.
We didn't buy the building.
We took over the master lease,
and then orchestrated it
from there.
It was just important to us.
It's like that
collaborative nature
of how we run the business,
how the cooks come up
with a menu with me.
It's like well, what do you
want to work with today?
Do you want to work with this?
And that collaborative
nature is very much
that neighborhood as well.
It's just getting good people
to do what they're good at.
Sightglass is just good people
that do good at what they do.
I think that was really,
really important to us.
I live above Flour + Water.
I live, literally,
above the restaurant.
AUDIENCE: So we are neighbors.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Yeah, we are neighbors.
Come over for a beer, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
I couldn't imagine
having these restaurants
in other parts of the city.
It's crazy.
I'm terrified of du Nord,
because it's a 10-minute drive
away.
And it's amazing
to be able to be
on that street and just
kind of hop around.
I don't even have
a home anymore.
I just hop around
from restaurant
to restaurant putting out fires.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Could you talk more about
the staging process,
and how maybe amateurs
or regular people would
go about doing that,
if that's an option?
Because I imagine it's
probably selective
for certain restaurants.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Certain restaurants
are really, really
strict about it.
The higher-end restaurants,
the higher you go,
sometimes they're more
and more strict about it.
If you're going to stage, you
have to sign a piece of paper,
and you have to stage
for at least 30 days.
Because they put so much time
and effort into having you
there, that they want it
to be beneficial for both
the restaurant and yourself.
Find the restaurant
that you want
to stage at, and then just
bug the hell out of the chef.
That's it.
Write him a bunch of emails.
The more novice--
CHRIS YING: Make
sure you tell them
Thomas told you to
do that, though.
I'm sure they'll
really appreciate that.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Yeah, no,
I've never met that guy before.
The more novice you are, it
depends on the restaurant.
If the restaurant's kitchen
is like this little shoebox,
it might be very, very
difficult to take you on,
because it takes time.
And when you're there, it's
like the two-way street.
I love it.
We have an open door policy.
And it's great, because when
someone's asking somebody
a question, it's forcing
them to retrain themselves.
So if you're on
garde-manger with a cook,
and you're like, well,
why do you do that?
The cook's like, well,
why do we do that?
Why don't we just put it there?
But it depends on the space.
The smaller the space,
the more difficult.
And every single
restaurant's different.
Sometimes they'll
just be like, you
have to stand in that corner.
And you're literally not
allowed to leave the corner.
And it just depends
on the restaurant.
AUDIENCE: So what's Flour
+ Water's policy on this?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Just email
the chef and just bug the hell
out of him.
I'm terrible at email.
I'm really bad.
It depends.
We have a ton of stages.
And then, if you just
contact the restaurant-- just
info@flourandwater-- and then
it fits in with the time--
If it fits in with
the time means
there's not a ton of
stages there, or depending
on what's going on, if
there's a ton of events,
if it fits the timing.
And then open-door policy.
Open-door policy for one day.
And then beyond that one
day, depends how you do.
CHRIS YING: Becomes
a closed-door policy.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Yeah.
But don't be offended if it is.
But it just depends
on that individual.
There's certain people that
come to the restaurant group
with zero experience,
and they're amazing.
They're awesome.
They just have a good attitude.
They want to be
taught what to do.
They want to get in there.
They have no problem
just jumping in.
And they're amazing.
There's people that come
to the restaurant with 20
years of experience,
and they're just a jerk.
They don't fit in here.
So it depends.
Every single person's
completely different.
AUDIENCE: So I studied
in Florence in college,
and my host grandmother would
make this just plain marinara.
It was the best
thing in the world.
And she would often joke.
She gave me the recipe, and
I've made it every summer since,
and it never tastes as good.
So I think part of it
might be just nostalgia.
But she often joked that
it's the soil in Italy,
and it's the very
specific types of tomatoes
that you're using and whatnot.
And so I was curious-- are
there any dishes or any flavors
that you've struggled to
recreate in San Francisco
that you tasted or
enjoyed in Bologna?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Yeah.
I think that terroir
is a real thing.
It's not just about
growing grapes.
You can take the same
grapevine, and you can grow it
in three different locations,
and it's the same grape.
It comes from the same vine.
And it's three completely
different glasses of wine
when you're all done with it.
That's true with anything.
We use San Marzano tomatoes.
We use incredibly,
incredibly local ingredients.
Our pigs come from 45
minutes above the restaurant.
That is because of the
terroir that is those pigs.
Could we buy some crazy, crazy
acorn-fed pork from Spain?
And it's incredibly-- the
marbling's ridiculous.
That's not our pork here.
I'd much rather use
our local ingredients.
And it just adds a nuance, or
a flavor nuance, to each dish
that you can't really explain.
And it's the same
thing with any food.
The San Marzano
tomatoes, San Marzanos.
you can grow the same
variety in California,
but they're San Marzano style.
Because those San
Marzanos in Italy
have come from a very
volcanic enriched soil.
So there's truth
to every product.
That's why I fell in love with
San Francisco and California
the first time.
Because when I first moved
out here, it was like,
well, shit-- this is
what sage tastes like?
Or that's the most
amazing turnip
I've ever had in my life.
That's crazy.
And it was just sage,
and it was just a turnip.
Most of our pork comes
from Devil's Gulch.
It's in Nicasio.
That's awesome for us.
It's a 45-minute drive.
We can go feed them
apples, and he'll
be on the menu in the
next couple of weeks.
It's amazing to see
that full circle.
And then also, he, now, because
we have such a relationship
with them, he grows pigs for us.
He grows pigs,
quails, lambs for us.
And we have control
over it-- from size
to weight to what they feed the
actual pigs, like the apples
and stuff like that.
And so, it's cool.
That, to me is a
responsibility of a chef
in northern California.
It's going beyond.
Because we're capable of
sourcing amazing ingredients,
it should be a part of
the job description.
AUDIENCE: When's
the last time you've
had dried store-bought pasta?
And--
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Uh--
AUDIENCE: Oh, go ahead.
You can answer.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: No, no, no--
AUDIENCE: The second one
is in the restaurant,
do you use SF tap water
when you're making pasta?
And maybe talk a little bit
about the flours you use?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: Sure.
The dried store-bought
pasta is not a bad thing.
We focus more on
northern Italian regions,
certainly with pasta.
When it becomes
summertime, and we
start growing the things that
are grown in southern Italy--
tomatoes, chilies,
peppers-- our menu
takes more of a southern Italian
influence in the summertime.
But when you think of
fresh pasta-- pappardelle,
garganelli, tagliatelle--
all those things?
That fresh pasta is from a
region in northern Italy.
Every single thing that
you see in the supermarket
is southern Italian pasta.
So spaghetti,
bucatini, rigatoni--
all those things are
southern Italian pasta.
Just because it's dried
doesn't mean it's bad.
There's some amazing
companies that
are in America that
have dried pastas.
We have an extruder.
All that comes from an extruder.
Means it's pushing
out through a die.
It's a mechanism.
And we extrude fresh.
So instead of having
dried spaghetti,
we make spaghetti
every single day.
And it's fresh.
It's pliable.
It has a completely
different texture.
So dried pasta
isn't a bad thing.
It's just specifically
from southern Italy.
And that's how it's bought
and sold there as well.
But no, there's some good
brands of dried pasta.
The
AUDIENCE: Water?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Oh, the water.
The argument with the water is
that it is more bread-making.
So there's zero yeast
inside of pasta.
Anything that's yeast-related.
So bagels is a big argument.
There's not a single good
bagel in San Francisco.
And then the nutrients, or lack
of nutrients, in that water,
and how it behaves with yeast.
And so, yeah, we
use San Francisco
tap water for everything.
And our bread's different.
We make all the bread
at the restaurant, too,
and it's different than
if we were making it
on the east coast.
But like I said, there's
people that fly in.
There's people that fly in water
to certain parts of the world
to make that New
York-style bagel.
Yeah, it's just
kind of crazy to me.
I love a good bagel
from the east coast.
CHRIS YING: All right.
Well, thank you guys for coming.
Thank you, sir, for coming.
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON:
Thanks for having us.
CHRIS YING: You're going to
sit around and sign some books,
or you have to go do a thing?
THOMAS MCNAUGHTON: We're going
to sign some books, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YING: Well, thanks, guys.